che freddo che fa qui hogwarts
perché mi corre così no e che per il
freddo mi si sono congelati bulbi
oculari non riesco più a muovere gli
occhi e li senti devi smetterla di
prendermi in giro guarda che hanno
capito che ti piaccia hey hey hey hey
hey hey ho capito che l'unico modo per
riscaldarci in queste talmente in
mezz'ora
parliamone no perché io in passato ho
già fatto un video nel quale min
mi chiedevo che che senso avessero le
scene di sesso in un film che poi non
fosse un porno come facessero girare
queste scene e come selezionassero le
attrici che poi avrebbero svolto la
parte della ragazza una botta e via
che poi viene queste ultime io me lo
immagino sempre quando devono presentare
un curriculum il conte jaakola
addirittura che ruolo aveva non mi
sembra di ricordarla anno è praticamente
io sono quella che viene posseduta
brutalmente da tanti ruberti e poi
uccisa
be nice quella della bara dell'ikea che
prime smontata poi viene montata dalle
il cancro penale con la barba e con le
ginocchia in fronte
no non ricordo il suo volto ma quello è
un segno di mika appunto dicevo sebbene
io abbia già parlato di tutte queste
belle cose
in passato non ho trattato un argomento
molto molto spinoso ecco diciamo che un
altro aspetto che non ho mai preso in
considerazione ma che necessita di un
minimo di attenzione da parte del mondo
e come tutte le idee geniali che si
rispetti non l'illuminazione mi ha colto
qualche giorno fa mentre sto vedendo un
film con mia madre
le proprie miss per colpa mia che stanno
facendo l'amore con te va bene
[Musica]
avete capito di cosa sto parlando
io son camillo lucio ma quello è
solamente perché tuoi l'intuito di di un
deumidificatore per l'ambiente la nuova
domanda che mi sono posto sulle sei
sesso è la seguente cosa fai quando a
guardarli insieme a te c'è un'altra
persona la prima cosa che fa mia madre
solitamente iniziare a parlare quindi di
qualsiasi cosa anche se non ha
effettivamente capito in si avvinghia e
chi si affanna e che sia bravo e dino
più perché non è vero
un grande stand proprio un film molto
reali c'è anche il regista ottobre i
fratelli sono fratelli davvero pensavo
di vincere la casa sia azzurro i
bastioni gran sasso non viviamo la parco
della vittoria che mi sembra un pochino
bulgari che mi dici al contrario i miei
fratelli poiché solitamente intervengono
con degli eleganti si affaccia dalle
famiglie è sempre stato un po
particolare un'altra abitudine che
abbiamo a casa e che io non capisco poi
è quella di coprire gli occhi le
orecchie la bocca poco ci manca che gli
si chieda pure di non respirare al mio
cugino piccolo in pratica quando vedremo
un film per adulti magari quelli col
bollino rosso quelle quel bull col
bollino giallo ma anche quelli con il
bollino verde forse lo faremo pure se
vedessi non lo so la melevisione
l'albero azzurro noi siamo lì sul chi va
là pronti a prendere la testa metterla
sotto la sabbia appena arriva un osceno
se qual è il problema è semplice che
subito dopo lo si lascia giocare ai
videogiochi i sanguinari dove si
ammazzano tutti quanti che vale oro
essere creativi e le morti sono né
divertente capito quindi a 1 st
le scapole all'altro non lo so napoli la
faccia sull'asfalto scambi il cervello
in giro non lo so come se fosse un
attacco di diarrea
come se fosse un attacco di diarrea su
un muro che poi ho sempre paura che
tutti i bambini ai quali si fa questa
cosa rischino di diventare dei serial
killer pazzi col tabù del sesso
finalmente siamo soli che a causa in
alto di mio marito io so come mi
divertivo a uccidere dei tetti su gratis
d'auto e gli dei dell'olimpo xi coda
investendolo con la macchina
fracassandogli le bambole pronostico
conto mia c da queste legalità al limite
della punizione divina
[Musica]
[Applauso]
va bene ma un altro problema è quello
del treno quando magari si sta vedendo
il film al computer e di colpo parte la
scena e tu hai paura che tutte le
persone che ti stanno attorno ti vedano
e pensino che chi che sia un maniaco
sessuale
in quel caso la cosa migliore da fare è
fingere nonchalance e guardare chi ti
guarda come se fosse un pervertito
la verità è una che se non bombardano
una storia cala l'attenzione e siccome
l'attenzione di chi sta guardando questo
video sarà già calata ecco un paio di
tette è un bel paio di peggiorare
dopo al prossimo video
il conto jacula addirittura il conte
jaakola addirittura il conte jacula
complimenti signor ea i conti jacula
unico che lo capiva il conti diavolo il
conte il diavolo conti ha curato il
continuo che pare il conti a cola
l'inizio delle riprese il conteggio culo
ma perché i conti aula il continuo e
conti aula il con dio
in carica che palle però